[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous ce jeudi 22 mars lors du
7-8 journal sur tv soixante dix huit
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de
cette édition la grande journée de grève
aujourd'hui dans la fonction publique et
à la sncf services et écoles fermées
galère dans les transports est la
mobilisation a largement perturbé le
quotidien des yvelinois un premier grand
test social pour le gouvernement dans ce
journal interview avec didier baichère
député est la république en marge des
yvelines autres contestations attrape où
certains parents d'élèves et enseignants
s'opposent à la mairie elle veut
instaurer de nouveaux rythmes scolaires
passées à 4 jours notamment pour la
maternelle une demande de dérogation a
été envoyé à l'éducation nationale et
puis c'est une semaine qui mêle arts et
sciences les rencontres in cité ont été
initiées par le théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines
une question est posée pour cette
deuxième édition serons-nous humain
demain reportages invités de ce journal
également hélène levasseur responsable
du centre de formation à des apprentis
de la fort pas à guyancourt
l'établissement forme aux métiers et des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité et des portes ouvertes ont lieu
ce samedi au campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité ouvrira
ses portes officiellement en septembre
dès la rentrée prochaine à guyancourt
quarante mille fonctionnaires et 25
mille cheminots mobilisés ce jeudi après
midi à paris il a été appelé à
manifester contre l'action du
gouvernement est la mobilisation a
débuté dès ce matin vous le voyez en
images à versailles une centaine de
syndicalistes de la cgt s'est rassemblée
devant la préfecture des yvelines
huit bus on crée ensuite la route de la
capitale les grévistes sont contre
l'externalisation des services publics
et dénonce la future suppression de 120
mille postes de fonctionnaires ils
demandent clairement au gouvernement de
reculer pour propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude des disques
des discussions des négociations nous on
y est favorable
il ya plein de choses qui peuvent être
améliorées
être sur la logique de supprimer 120
mille postes c'est ça qu'ils nous
préparent dont 70 mille postes dans la
fonction publique territoriale
c'est inconcevable quand on voit
l'explosion des besoins il ya eu la
période de temps et souvent par exemple
les épisodes neigeux où tout le monde se
disait ça va pas ça va pas assez vite
mais derrière ces des moyens le problème
il est juste là dessus en fait si ça met
du temps à déneiger c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas ces nombres c'est très concret
c'est très basique
donc si un message peut passer
aujourd'hui auprès de monsieur macron
c'est ok pour négocier mais à négocier
c'est pour améliorer le service public
pas pour le détériorer st pourra jamais
accepter ça et le mouvement de grève de
la fonction publique a concerné
également aujourd'hui météo france à
trappes 30 % des salariés ont débrayé
comme 29 autres centres de prévision en
france le site de trappes va fermer
d'ici 2022 est 500 emplois en péril et
qui viendrait s'ajouter déjà 700 postes
supprimés depuis 2012 un risque à terme
pour la qualité la précision des
prévisions au niveau local selon les
grévistes est météo france ne compterait
plus que 2500 agents en 2022
interview réalisée par michael et demi
d'euros c'est à dire qu'il y aurait plus
de prévisions qui serait fait pour sur
les yvelines et sur le val d'oise depuis
trappe comme c'est fait actuellement
mais ça sera fait à partir de
saint-mandé dans le val-de-marne où se
trouve la actuellement la direction de
météo france et la direction régionale
ile de france centre
au niveau des prévisions de proximité
comme on a besoin pour ce qu'on appelle
la viabilité hivernale c'est à dire
l'état des routes pendant l'hiver on
sait que ça avoir de grosses
répercussions
on a vu déjà pas mal de problèmes cet
hiver avec les épisodes des jeux est là
avec une absence de proximité ça risque
est extrêmement compliquée pour les
usagers est la journée de grève a bien
sûr créer des perturbations écoles et
services fermés condition est difficile
aussi dans les transports ce jeudi matin
à la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
nombreuses étaient les voyageurs
impactés pas de trafic sur la ligne e u
1 train sur 2 sur la ligne n aucune
circulation entre plaisir et dreux et
puis une rame sur trois pour le rer c
les usagers pour la plupart agacé ont dû
prendre leur mal en patience
écoutez quelques réactions collectées
par michael et demi d'euros j'en
apprends que faut prendre la ligne c'est
pourtant une correspondance bon il ya
quand même pas mal de personnes
mobilisées 1
les gens qui sont là pour les renseigner
mais bon après ça on sait tous que ça va
être compliqué qu'on de tous organisés y
a pas de train il ya aucun train n'était
pas rentrée chez nous et
voilà passé
ces traits de même pas envie d'aller
travailler même d'aller à l'école de la
combattre a bien se greffent bon là ça
là c'est vraiment vraiment embêtant pour
le coup c'est très dérangeant
donc là moi d'habitude je prends la
ligne et donc j'ai pas du tout le
travail et c'est très embêtant une
certaine lassitude 1 c'est sûr qu'on a
des contraintes professionnelles comme
comme les gens de la sncf
donc après nous signe donc on doit
pouvoir s'en remet à l'eau du travail
donc après moment nous si on peut en
payer les pots cassés
selon les retards consumer health cette
journée du jeudi 22 mars qui a été aussi
l'occasion de faire remonter d'autres
griefs contre le gouvernement comme pour
cette dizaine d'élèves qui a bloqué ce
matin l'accès au lycée la bruyère à
versailles et mobilisation à l'appui
notamment du mouvement générations
contre la plate-forme d'admission
postbac parcours sup lancé en ce début
d'année elle instaure une forme de
sélection à l'entrée des universités
selon à ses opposants
pour parler de ce grand mouvement de
grève aujourd'hui didier baichère est
avec nous par téléphone mon sort
autant vous êtes le député la république
en marge de la première circonscription
des yvelines alors aujourd'hui cette
grande journée de grève c'est le premier
vrai test social pour le gouvernement
c'est une journée j'imagine que vous
avez suivi avec attention
oui bien sûr c'est une journée que j'ai
tué avec la tension et puis
malheureusement c'est comme tous les
noirs suivi les conséquences de cette
grève
je me déplace en transport en commun
donc j'ai été moi-même très impacté par
les difficultés de transport donc il
n'est pas facile
skins que l'état soit il et je partage
cette difficulté avec tous ceux qui ont
été victimes de cette grève
voilà je dois dire que j'ai un petit peu
de mal avec le principe de la grève
préventive puisque vous savez que pour
ce qui concerne la sncf dans un
processus de dialogue qui est ouvert
avec les syndicats
j'ai une vingtaine de réunions qui ont
eu lieu avec eux il ya deux mois de
concertation qui sont prévus pour par
les dieux du plan d'évolution de la sncf
la sncf un avenir d'ailleurs voilà j'ai
un petit peu de mal à comprendre quel
est l'objectif d'une grève alors qu'on
est en discussion et qu'on est vraiment
dans une posture d'écouté avec les
organisations syndicales
mais le gouvernement
va vite beaucoup de lois votées vous le
dites il ya déjà des projets également
sur la table qui sont en cours alors les
fonctionnaires eux mobiles se sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui notamment alors
motivé grief le gel du point d'indicé
l'instauration aussi du jour de carence
vous parliez des cheminots et de cette
réforme du rail qui est en préparation
vous comprenez cette mobilisation nous
disiez un instant ces mobilisations
préventif c'est vous vous les comprenez
pas forcément c'est ça moi je pense que
je comprends toute manifestation et et
toute difficulté que telle ou telle
personne syndicats peuvent exprimer
c'est en ça que nous sommes dans une
posture d'écouté après je pense que sur
les fonctionnaires pour la mobilisation
d'ailleurs des fonctionnaires a pas
vraiment été très importante mais on a
garanti qu'il n'y aurait pas de perte de
pouvoir d'achat par rapport à la
compensation de la cg dont je crois
qu'il ya déjà des messages qui ont été
qui ont été adressées pour les cheminots
bien sûr les cheminots ont un travail
avec des contraintes très spécifique
n'est que doivent penser les ouvriers du
bâtiment que doivent chanter les
commerçants qui eux mêmes ont des
contraintes d'horaire avec le week-end
travail très tôt le matin sont pour les
ouvriers du bâtiment soumis aux aléas du
temps j'ai envie d'aller à plein
aujourd'hui de deux corps de métier de
branches professionnelles qui sont
soumises à des aléas et qui trouvent des
accords avec les syndicats pour pas dire
que vous allez avoir à ce qu'on dit
c'est que le test des cheminots il date
de 1920 je pense qu'il est temps de le
faire évoluer et on va le faire dans un
esprit de concertation et dans l' écoute
donc vous êtes ouverts à la négociation
c'est ce que vous dites elle fait
totalement vert est justement
négociations a encore une fois il ya
déjà vingt réunions qui ont eu lieu il
ya deux mois de concertation qui sont
prévues avec les organisations
syndicales de cheminots ils le savent
quand alger dès que j'ai un peu de mal
avec ce concept de grève préventive
alors qu'on est dans une train de
négocier discuter traite ouvertement
mais merci à didier baichère d'abord
être avec nous député à l'om de la
première circonscription dit
yveline merci d'avoir été avec nous
elles les rythmes scolaires également
dans l'actualité ils font débat attrape
depuis que la mairie a réclamé une
dérogation au ministère de l'éducation
nationale la ville souhaite conserver
une semaine de quatre jours et demi en
élémentaire mais veut repasser à quatre
jours pour la maternelle ce qui ne passe
pas auprès de certains syndicats et
enseignants ils dénoncent notamment la
perte d'heures de cours pour les plus
petits explications avec ce sujet de
nicolas kirillovitch et patrick jacques
de dixmude dans le froid et sous les
fenêtres de l'inspection de l'éducation
nationale enseignants et syndicats
locaux expriment leur désaccord
ils sont opposés au projet de la ville
de trappes sur les rythmes scolaires un
projet qui conserverait le rythme actuel
de quatre jours et demi pour les
écoliers élémentaire mais qui
basculerait à quatre jours pour les
maternelles sans rattrapage des heures
supprimées
c'est un principe d'égalité inscrit dans
la constitution dont il n'est pas a
fortiori sur un territoire comme
celui-ci acceptable que l'on diminue le
nombre d'heures d'enseignement au delà
de ça ce que nous demandons c'est le
retour à quatre jours les quatre jours
et demi sur trappe
n'ayant absolument pas fait la preuve de
leur dette satisfaisante des rythmes
différents maternelle et en élémentaire
une première qui nécessitait l'accord du
ministère de l'éducation nationale pour
justifier cette innovation le maire de
la ville assure qu'il cherche la
meilleure solution pour les enfants est
garanti que rien n'est encore décidé
vous pourrez avoir des éléments
différents en temps et en rythmes et par
rapport aux primaires il ya des enfants
en maternelle surtout la toute petite
section qui sort utilisons qui sont
fatigués donc est-ce qu'on a une réponse
ou pas on peut pas décider ça tout seul
donc attendre la réponse du ministre
pour continuer à manifester leur
opposition enseignants et syndicats
prévoit d'intervenir lors du prochain
conseil municipal mardi le ministère lui
n'a pas encore répondu à la demande de
dérogation formulées par la mairie un
hôpital des nounours la phrase peuvent
faire sourire c'est l'opération qui est
est organisée aujourd'hui par des
étudiants en médecine de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
l'objectif c'est montrer au plus petit
que l'hôpital n'est pas un endroit si
est dramatique et leur enseigne
également quelques notions médicales et
d'hygiène de nouveau nicolas
kirillovitch et patrick jacques de
dixmude bien tu vois ça pourra les
mettre sur la panne de tongzhou savalas
toute droite les autres mais
qu'arrive-t-il à l'ila le doudou de
noémie à manosque et bay hill assez du
vélo et les tombées et alors qu'est ce
qui se passe
il s'est cassé la patte si lille a s'est
cassé la patte il faut donc aller à
l'hôpital pour la soigner
l'hôpital ces murs blancs ces piqûres et
ses grandes blues
un lieu qui peut effrayer les enfants et
c'est pour contrer ce sentiment qu'un
dispensaire provisoire s'est installé à
versailles il ya des enfants quand on
leur demande si ça fait un peu ce que
c'est d'aller jeunes médecins l'hôpital
et tout ça il rattache beaucoup à des
maladies très graves
l'hôpital c'est la mort ou des choses
comme ça et là on leur montre que
finalement non à l'hôpital il ya plein
de gens qui sont soignés que toutes les
maladies ne sont pas graves qu'à
l'échelle médecin c'est pas grave pour
vaincre la peur plusieurs ateliers sont
organisés avec doudou même l'accès au
bloc opératoire se fait dans des
conditions presque réel organisé par
l'association au poème solidarité cette
matinée à l'hôpital des nounours a
également une portée pédagogique
apprendre à bien se brosser les dons ou
connaître par coeur les numéros
d'urgence les enfants apprennent en
s'amusant et en imaginant quand on leur
demande quelle doudou il ne trouve plein
de choses
il écoute le coeur du tout et tout fin
c'est vraiment génial
et donc là ils sont vraiment à la geôle
imaginaire va être le plus fort est ici
nous arrive à se concentrer suffisamment
pour que ça fonctionne voix et pour voir
si le tout a bien fonctionné les
étudiants en médecine passeront la
semaine prochaine en classe pour prendre
des nouvelles et des doudous ordinateurs
jeux vidéo tablettes et smartphones les
écrans se multiplient autour de nous et
nous les utilisons de plus en plus
jeunes pour jouer ou encore utiliser les
réseaux sociaux mardi la ville de
montigny le bretonneux organisait une
conférence débat des spécialistes sur le
sujet ont pu donner quelques clés aux
parents pour un bon usage de ces
nouvelles technologies
éviter les pièges ne pas tomber dans une
addiction ou encore faire preuve
d'esprit critique face aux contenus
auxquels peuvent être confrontés les
jeunes propos recueillis sur place par
patrick jacques de dixmude jeu le
message que ans qu'on va faire passer
c'est tout simplement pas au niveau de
la parentalité
c'est qu'on doit accompagner nos enfants
à utiliser internet c'est comme donner
un vélo sans roues ou sans code de la
route
c'est donc il faut à comprendre
accompagner ses enfants
il ya des solutions multiples il faut
savoir cadre est effectivement les
écrans et savoir les gérer au niveau des
paramètres savoir ce qui regarde dedans
et à apprendre une certaine éducation à
transmettre à l'enfant pour qu'il puisse
avoir les clés de décryptage pour
comprendre ce qu'ils voient elle édite
des jeux de société à succès comme
jungle speed ou encore times up la
société à ce mode est implantée à
guyancourt n'en finit plus de se
développer à des centaines de millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires croissance
à deux chiffres une visite était
organisée aujourd'hui avec les élus
locaux l'occasion notamment de découvrir
la récente extension du site
or ils iront étaient sur place salle de
repos avec billards et baby-foot
cafétéria ambiance dinner un esprit
californien et pourtant nous sommes à
guyancourt où se situe la société
asmodée 150 personnes travaillent ici on
mise surtout sur effectivement des
espaces et des conditions de travail
idéales et on joue effectivement sur
oui le bien-être au travail c'est un peu
facile quand on s'appelle à sokodé et
qu'on distribue en fait on est dite ou
distribuer des jeux de société
l'entreprise qui a réalisé en 2010 7 450
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
possède un catalogue de plus de 2000
références parmi les plus gros succès
jungle speed time's up ou encore les
cartes pokémon le siège s'est implanté
puis récemment étendu sur un terrain
vendu par saint quentin en yvelines
en tout douze mille mètres carrés c'est
la société j'ai fait qui a réalisé les
travaux asmodée ayant voulu rester sur
le territoire pour asseoir son
développement nous avons pas de joint
une deuxième tranche de locaux de 2000
m² de bureaux et intégrée 90 parking en
sous sol faisant en sorte qu'à ce modèle
puisse rester sur le territoire et dans
son bâtiment d'origine groupe continue à
se développer
c'est un peu dans notre adn je crois ce
développement
je pense qu'effectivement le jeu encore
voilà de belles années devant nous
leader européen des jeux de société à ce
mode et se définit comme un groupe
français à dimension internationale
la société emploie d'ailleurs plus de
600 personnes à travers le monde
c'est ce samedi à guyancourt le centre
de formation des apprentis de la forme
organise sa journée portes ouvertes
c'est sur son futur site d'implantation
le campus des services de l'automobile
et de la mobilité qui ouvrira
officiellement ses portes à la rentrée
de septembre 2018 bonsoir hélène
levasseur vous êtes la responsable de ce
cfa à fort pas sur le campus de
guyancourt donc là fort pas qu'ils
forment aux métiers de l'automobile par
l'alternance en ile-de-france alors la
faire passer c'est une association
quelles sont ses missions
c'est un centre de formation en fait par
alternance préparant aux métiers des
services de l'automobile alors mécanique
carrosserie peinture c'est vrai que sur
le site de guyancourt nous allons
proposer une offre exclusivement tournée
vers la maintenance des véhicules donc
mécanique du préapprentissage au bts
avec quelques quelques nouveautés donc
un cqp un contrat de qualification
dépanneurs remorqueurs ainsi qu'un
technicien expert après vente automobile
je vais utiliser le futur pour lui
encore parce que ça sera partiel à la
rentrée de septembre c'est à quoi je
viens de remporter la seule sans coût
tout à fait c'est une c'est une entité
donc qui qui se développera et qui
débutera en fait à la rentrée donc 2018
un temps c'est vrai que le campus c'est
une entité beaucoup plus importante que
l'info repas oui c'était faire et du
coup là fort pas sur une île de france
est implanté en plusieurs endroits
exactement donc six centres en fait sont
présents en ile-de-france le site des
sites à la celle-saint-cloud
savigny-sur-orge saint maurice à
vaux-le-pénil coulommiers et issy les
moulineaux parce que c'est la même offre
de formation qui est dispensée sur
chaque site où ces différentes effet pas
tout à fait mille deux cents apprentis
donc sont présents en alternance donc
comme je vous le disais dans les métiers
de la maintenance mécanique carrosserie
peinture
on fait également un petit peu de
véhicules industriels et quelques
quelques particularités avec des
contrats de professionnalisation est ce
que ces métiers de l'automobile
recrutait ce qu'on a une chance de
trouver un emploi au sortir de sa
formation
alors aujourd'hui la formation évolue on
propose des niveaux assez large
préapprentissage jusqu'au bts
il est important aujourd'hui de
poursuivre ses études commencées avec un
ca fait et très bien poursuivre est
important dans la mesure où aujourd'hui
les véhicules évoluent les techniques
évoluent on arrive à des véhicules
connectés il faut impérativement
poursuivre sa formation
la branche de l'automobile elle est
varié il ya beaucoup de possibilités
suta fait
le campus en fait à cette vocation il
souhaite mettre en avant justement les
nouvelles technologies les nouveaux
usages pour adapter les compétences en
fait aux enjeux de demain dans tous les
secteurs automobiles et motocycles à et
cycle alors on l'a dit donc ce cfa fort
passera à planter à partir de la rentrée
2010 8 sur ce tout nouveau campus des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité à guyancourt qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça change concrètement
d'être sur une sur cette structure
d'être sur ce campus il y aura plusieurs
organismes de formation dont la forme
pas qu'est ce que ça change concrètement
alors ce que ça change en fait déjà
l'idée
c'est de proposer une offre qui
permettent de trouver justement toutes
les possibilités de la maintenance donc
l'automobile du motocycle du cycle
l'idée est bien évidemment organi
d'organiser entre guillemets une
mutualisation également des équipements
d'optimiser aussi les coûts de
fonctionnement
et de proposer une offre de service le
plus innovantes possible en
développement encore une fois ces
nouvelles technologies
ce pôle it et c'est d'en faire un pôle
un pôle d'excellence tout à fait l'idée
c'est véritablement de créer une vitrine
des métiers de l'automobile est bien
évidemment un pôle d'excellence
alors pour cette journée portes ouvertes
de samedi on le rappelle ça se déroule
de 10h à 16h si j'ai pas de bêtises a
tout à fait là 9h07 heure il s'agit d'un
événement en effet puisque c'est la
première ouverture au public seront
proposées diverses diverses animations
des démonstrations d'activités
d'apprentis des quiz des conférences la
nef a donc l'association nationale pour
la formation automobile
organise une grande conférence sur nos
métiers ont de l'avenir
durant laquelle seront présentées les
différentes filières de formation ainsi
que les véhicules connectés
ouverte au public bien évidemment cette
conférence ce site il est terminée il y
encore les derniers détails
il est encore bon il est encore en
chantier les travaux avancent très bien
il sera opérationnel dès septembre il
nous reste moins d'une minute comment on
fait pour intégrer justement ce cfa où
vient la jpo déjà pour commencer on
prend contact avec les différents
centres de formation parce que l'intérêt
faire l'important c'est bien évidemment
d'avoir une entreprise pour débuter sa
formation en septembre mais prendre
contact de façon à recevoir un
accompagnement et toutes les
informations nécessaires auprès des
centres de formation donc un fort pas
yens cm pour la moto
le gars ac bien évidemment toute
dernière chose le coût du cursus 0
normalement des frais d'inscription
d'accord mais mr merci hélène levasseur
d'avoir été avec nous est la responsable
de ce cfa à forme mabhouh qui ouvrira
ses portes officiellement aghion cours à
la rentrée prochaine sur le campus des
métiers l'automobile et de la mobilité
plus d'informations sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
serons-nous humains encore demain c'est
le thème des deuxièmes rencontres il
cité elles ont été initiées par le
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une semaine de
réflexion est mêlant art et science
mardi dernier trois chercheurs ont
échangé sur le sujet réparer les vivants
reportage de mélanie poker
de l'homme qui valait trois milliards à
oscar pistorius la réalité a parfois
rattraper la fiction où en est la
science des feuillants réparer les
vivants une question qui nourrit des
fantasmes le thème d'une table ronde
mardi soir au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines
ça passe par des robots de rééducation
où des robots d'assistance dans le cas
où il ya pas de récupération possible
par exemple des prothèses de membres ont
fourni des aides apps des outils qui
répondent à des besoins très spécifiques
mais encore pas de solutions
polyvalentes ou extrêmement adaptable
pour pour rendre leur autonomie au
patient
on sait très bien réparé on sait réparer
des danses et réparer des os fracturés
ça c'est tout à fait clair régénérer
plus compliqué l'idée de la régénération
c'est de restituer l'intégrité complète
du tissu une heure d'échangés autour
d'un thème pour comprendre que la
fiction pilote parfois les innovations
mais peut susciter des décalages de
compréhension en réalité la situation
est quand même beaucoup plus complexe
que ça il ya beaucoup de progrès à faire
même sur la fait déjà énormément de
progrès et les résistances elles sont
elles sont corporelle elle son physique
elles sont sociales elles sont elles
sont très diverses et la technologie ne
peut pas être une réponse à tous les
échanges avec le public continue
prochaines réflexions l'homme augmenté
un retour en arrière pour refermer ce
journal
inoubliable membres des deschiens le
comédien françois morel est aussi
chanteur sur scène il rend hommage
un hommage facétieux au music hall et à
la haye à la vie un hommage à la vie
l'artiste était au prisme d'elancourt
samedi dernier
mélanie poker et nicolas landry l'ont
suivi
[Musique]
suspendu
françois morel vous raconte des
histoires celle d'une vie de plusieurs
vies le comédien devient chanteur et
célèbre la vie en jouant avec tous ses
aspects l'intérêt d'un récital c'est de
pouvoir jouer un peu sur des
sensibilités différentes c'est un petit
peu les montagnes russes un spectacle de
chansons c'est à dire qu'on peut faire
une chanson très légère et humoristique
juste après une chanson plus pathétique
et puis revenir une chanson comique et c
est donc celle eu le plaisir de jouer
avec les différents sentiments mais je
veux pas dire qu'il ya une seule source
d'inspiration en a plein un récital à
l'ancienne en hommage au music hall
accompagné de trois furies musiciens
celui qu'on connaît comédien et
chroniqueur valent son humour et revient
à ses premières amours
quand j'étais jeune j'ai essayé de
m'accompagner à la guitare mais j'étais
pas très bon et ça me faisait très mal
au bout des doigts donc j'ai abandonné
la guitare et j'ai fait comédien et puis
après quand je suis devenu une grosse
boulette
non mais quand tu es une femme nue un
peu mieux connue j'ai travaillé avec des
musiciens qui pouvaient m'accompagner et
donc j'ai pu renouer avec mon amour de
jeunesse la vie titre provisoire est un
spectacle fait pour les gens pour le
partage séance de rattrapage à paris le
4 mai prochain
la vie série
non
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal demain
vendredi ne ratez pas l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine yvelinoise
avec le 7-8 l'hebdo de nicolas
kirillovitch camille lambert elle vous
donnera les meilleures idées de sorties
du week end dans son set 8 loisirs et ce
journal il est à revoir bien sûr sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]